With the harsh winters in the Canadian province of Quebec,...
...people in Montreal love to celebrate the sunshine.
The tamtam has become a tradition on most Sundays from noon to sunset...
...throughout the warmer months.
Tamtam is French for hand drums,...
...and there are a lot of groups drumming with various beats.
A mixture of different music styles is wafting from all directions.
You can buy hand drums from vendors on Avenue du Parc and join in.
It takes place near the monument to Sir George-Étienne Cartier...
...and in the surrounding green spaces of Parc du Mont-Royal.
Hundreds of people, visitors, and locals spend an afternoon enjoying the music and the sun.
If drums are not your thing, you can take your preferred musical instrument...
...or you can just enjoy listening.
It's all free and anything goes.
If you like lighthearted summer days with music, this is a good place.